[Music]
so there's some different supermarkets
which are testing this new pay
technology um basically you just pay for
your groceries this is the walk out one
kind well no it's even better it's like
whole uh whole foods right no no amazon
stores amazon stores specifically have
these like amazon stores where you just
like scan in your um
like prime membership or whatever yeah
you walk in you take stuff off the
office yeah because that's it's all
sensor based yeah and there's cameras
and [ __ ] and then you just walk out and
it just automatically charges scans it
as you put it in the cart yeah i heard a
whole food just gonna do that soon
because amazon owns whole foods yeah wow
yeah so you don't have to check out it's
just it just knows what you're doing
once you enter the space because of your
phone that's a little spooky yeah but
how would they know the weight of the
vegetables that's the one i always don't
know maybe maybe there's maybe there's
like scales in the carts
i didn't think of that scales and the
trays too
maybe it's maybe it's a trust thing
because you know i was thinking like
with all these self-checked out like
kiosks right
i'm thinking the theft must be so much
more now because it's so much easier to
be like i'm gonna scan this but i won't
scan this how often do you guys do this
i [ __ ] do it all the time no i mean i
paid for all the time
well it sounded like the opposite it's
completely different all the time i
thought i thought he just went in cargo
pants and he's like this goes in here
oh there's that cargo guy again
who wears cargo shirts anymore somehow
has the cargo jingles that are no longer
around them
bananas come in my pockets yeah just the
rave pants yeah but i'm always thinking
about it right because i'm like
no one's actually watching me when the
person goes to check your receipt they
don't even check how many items you got
in this they're just like highlighter
here you go
you want to know the smartest way to
police that
is uh because because these amazon fresh
markets are technically mostly like
upscale like white people they'll tell
on you
they don't need security
that's the real honor system i just saw
that guy with the cargo put a bunch of
oranges
and then you incented and you
incentivize snitching yeah you
incentivize yeah you get a free ten
dollar amazon gift card for every person
you snitch out and one didn't pay for
their muffins
yo just get stitches though
it's true
so no it's not the amazon uh fresh type
of technology it's actually
pay face technology
i don't like that yeah they're testing
it right now in brazil i don't know why
specifically brazil are trying it out in
supermarkets but you pay with a smile
you gotta scan your face on a thing like
what if you scowl so it's the same thing
as a regular market except like once
everything's been scanned and the totals
on the screen you just go
and it goes
so it's like saving your face is like
the billing information or whatever
exactly that's kind of like your phone
right like you could unlock your phone
with your face yeah it's exactly like
that what if there's look-alikes cause
that's your that's why you guys smile
because look people won't be able to
duplicate your exact smiles
maybe maybe twins can do it actually
it's kind of actually terrifying right
because like these companies so let's
look at the bigger grand scale picture
like amazon isn't an e-commerce company
their data company right
tesla is not a car company their data
company so imagine like all this facial
recognition that they're picking up this
is like super blade runner-esque where
like a crime could happen and like your
face resembles this other person and
then they instantly arrest you kind of
thing because like facial recognition
isn't a hundred percent yeah
like imagine like like everyone everyone
in the world has a doppelganger or
multiple doppelgangers of them around
the world even elon musk does
yeah dude
yeah so it's pretty interesting that
they're gonna do that uh kind of funny
too if you're not in the mood to when
you're painting
sir you have to smile
luna went down
freaking finances declined anyway yeah
you can't buy no groceries yeah that's
crazy you know as like in the crypto
space we want to be more anonymous
borderless
we're going completely against that
we're now we're checking out their
facial recognition like when when is it
that that we as as people say all right
man that you guys got too way too much i
mean i mean they they see my face when
i'm like on pornhub like from my phone
but like but like where's the light you
know where's the light you know those
you know those porn sites where like you
didn't know it was taking cookie
so then you sign on you're like how did
it know i liked all these things
i didn't even type anything yet
[Laughter]
it remembers your last visit it's like
oh yeah here's some freaking new ones
that the one you like and now you're
scrolling dude
they're both
um not actually opposite but they're in
the same direction with uh so like the
borderless and um anonymous i think for
crypto
the ultimate goal is convenience and
scanning your face the ultimate goal is
convenience dude [ __ ] that though i
don't think it's convenient i don't
think convenience is the ultimate goal
is it because i think for people for the
consumer right like if you're like when
you're going like this yeah people like
this because you don't have to press
something eight times right so with
crypto same thing like you could buy
anything anywhere without government
regulation it's just if i have a
transaction between you and me
why do i need escrow why do i need a
broker or an agent that's the also the
anonymous part of it i don't think that
like convenience at least for what i
understand about crypto the appeal is
not necessarily that it's convenient
it's that it's saying [ __ ] the
government and [ __ ] the fed yeah like so
it's that's that's the convenience
convenience there is
going around the government time they
could read every transaction on the
blockchain too
yeah i think the bigger conversation is
who owns that data yeah because of web3
and crypto technically you own that data
it's interfacing with your wallet you're
the one that shares the information
right right but like in the web we'll
call it web 2 world the amazons the
facebooks you are the product and they
collect the data and they own the data
so they're all new they don't they
effectively so they can figure out how
to get you to buy more they can kind of
see your patterns
even like on your apple maps the tracks
where you go they're like oh this guy
likes to go to 7-eleven every morning at
8am let's start selling them some more
7-eleven kind of things right
yeah and everything they like to go to
zion they must be they might they like
to go camping let's sell them some
camping rei [ __ ] you know what's your
ideal uh pay method would you like it if
it if it took a photo of your fight
stance
did they make fun of you after it's
really you it's like faces one stance is
two
what about some good old-fashioned
bartering dude just go into the store
and be like i'll give you 10 peanuts for
that one banana
that's a good deal yeah you know parker
rick
do some bartering dude some grassroots
bartering because the more convenient
things get it has to invade your privacy
more sure yeah right like like like elon
musk talks about our thumbs are what's
limiting the bandwidth right so if you
want what you're thinking to happen then
this needs to be in your brain yeah so
it's good that's like the ultimate
invasion of privacy where it invades
your your your body yeah your body
that's true because if you're like a
homesteader out in the middle of nowhere
it is the least convenient way to live
but the most anonymous yeah yeah yeah
because you got to get your water you're
not tapped to the grid you gotta
you gotta make your own food yeah they
don't know how many tomatoes you have
i'm just gonna go amish you gotta go
full amish amish dude full almost yeah
crypto needs to go home
[Laughter]
and [ __ ] come on dude decentralized dude
you know they don't pay taxes really
yeah they don't pay taxes
no because they um they argued
a long time ago that they don't receive
any of the government services so why
should they pay taxes that's a good
point
because they're like they don't need any
of the electricity they don't need any
of anything like how do we just claim
amish don't claim amish i think a bunch
of people try with their [ __ ]
sovereign citizens would i put that on
my w-2 do you feel on me
come on
you identify as amish none of these
government services you gotta take a
test yeah it's all [ __ ] up so you get
a tooth get tooth egg now you get pulled
out yeah that's that's fine it's like
blood support there you go you don't
look like commissioner
[Laughter]
grow my beard out are you guys more for
like convenience or privacy or where are
you guys there's a balance there's
definitely a balance it's not anybody
scanning my face yeah i feel like being
sold the things that i didn't know
existed that i want yeah i sort of like
it but that's what google is though
google like if you guys ever checked
your google preferences where they
create your personality and they're able
to track all the things that you're
interested in whether you're single
whether you're married like whether
you're a father they can track every
little thing and it's like a hundred
points
and it's it's pretty fascinating when
you read through it you realize how well
their algorithm is to know exactly who
you are oh my god and that's why they
could predict when you need like you
know yeah [ __ ] tampons or something
in your instagram ads at least for me i
don't know about you guys yeah nick your
[ __ ] tampon
subscription is coming in it's good [ __ ]
like there's this classic case that what
happened was this dad was getting really
mad at target for serving his daughter
ads about diapers and stuff like that
like what are you trying to say like my
kids shouldn't be having a kid right now
she's a teenager
and then so what actually the way the
algorithm worked was it was able to see
based on her search history that she's
more predisposed to becoming a mother is
it because she was hispanic and from
bellflower
maybe imagine that's all you need and so
she was being served these ads for
formula and diaper and so she ended up
revealing to her father yes she was
pregnant oh [ __ ]
so that's how good these are
she shouldn't have bought the pregnancy
test with wi-fi on it
the bluetooth ones are good though
there's so many there's so many of those
test things that connect to your phone
now i'm like why is this really yeah we
connected wi-fi pregnancy
there's covet tests that are like have
like an app and [ __ ] like that like i
don't need a [ __ ] code test for them
you know right now we have this whole
reverse weighed situation in supreme
court so what a lot of women figured out
was there's this menstrual
cycle thing that's connected to your app
right you're like disconnected because
now they're gonna know
when you're menstruating and potentially
pregnant like it could open up this
whole can of worms
so we live in this crazy like
interconnected society today and then at
what point do we say okay this is way
too much we've just got to go a little
bit more amish i want to go full robot
full amish
full robot but in the amish neighborhood
so you're just going to be figured it
out robot jebediah he's good he's going
to be the most explained
i don't care i'm good
he's going to be the like most hated
person in that community because he's
just like
flaunting his just like check out my new
robot you're in the amish community
but he's not even posing he's just like
he's just like i'm just gonna be close
enough to annoy you
everyone's plowing their land with the
horse and you just see joey
[Laughter]
[Music]
you